I want to have a brief update with you
about what's going on in Arizona and in
America Fest and with the Arizona
gubernatorial election it's actually
becoming even more cartoonish and
pathetic and humiliating than what we
saw after the 2020 election with Donald
Trump Carrie Lake who lost the 2022
Arizona gubernatorial election that's it
there's no other there's that's the
story she lost her opponent got more
votes she is now calling for a new
election and there are people around her
who seem to be encouraging her we're
going to go to our first clip this is
from the the last whimpers of America
Fest an event put on by turning point
USA here is Carrie Lake speaking to
Charlie Kirk and they now want a new
election in Arizona
all that happened is Carrie Lake lost
understand that what is the remedy we're
asking for I think that we need a new
election I think that there needs to be
a new election
you can't have the same clowns running
this election we can't put it back into
the hands of people who have bungled the
election time and time again and yes now
that's there's an important little
detail in there which is in some
alternate universe which we might enter
in the next clip I'm going to show you
by the way but in some alternate
universe where you get a new election
you know that if they did the election
and then Kerry Lake lost again they
would just say
the same people ran this election this
election was just as biased and
fraudulent and rigged as the first one
and we know that that would happen
because it's what it's what we see when
they do recounts in audits every single
time you get an audit to the ex and
again when you say an audit what is it
that they want
they do an audit and it turns out the
result was fine or even that the
Democrat actually won by more and then
they come back and they say that wasn't
really an audit
all they did was recount the same
fraudulent ballots we need signature
verification we need curing we need
sauteing and smoking and Grilling we
need to do all these things to the
ballots uh to figure out whether these
should even be counted because at the
end of the day
they will adjust their allegation of
what happened
simply to fit whatever narrative they
need at that moment at one point the
problem in Arizona was people didn't get
to vote and that hurt Carrie Lake
because of tabulators and power circuits
and all these different printers people
who wanted to vote didn't get to vote
then the story shifted to so many people
voted in Arizona who shouldn't even have
voted and it was and tons of Republicans
voted and their votes were counted for
Katie Hobbs wait a second was the
problem that Republicans weren't able to
vote or was the problem that Republicans
were able to vote in huge numbers but
tons of their votes were counted with
Katie Hopps which of the two is actually
the problem
and it's both depending on what's going
on one other really funny moment from
this interview with Charlie Kirk Carrie
Lake explains her process for hiring
attorneys and it's it's pretty damn
funny and it was a valley-wide Ambush is
what happened absolutely absolutely 100
and and they're trying to tell us this
is normal par for the core don't insult
hey Steven Richard don't insult my
intelligence we know what you're up to
and we're gonna we're gonna put you on
the stand and ask you a few tough
questions so right I feel very confident
my team is great my attorneys are true
Patriots we had attorneys who did walk
away because the left is threatening
them with their ability to make a living
and practice law and some of our
attorneys said look I got mouths to feed
I can't do this case I don't want to be
sanctioned so I I really love I got to a
point where I said I'll take anybody
we'll take Better Call Saul come on
are you a patriot are you willing to
fight are you willing to risk everything
on this very important case and that's
who we have assembled true Fighters and
we're going to court tomorrow and
Thursday and we hope for a quick uh you
know ruling
it's evident that absolutely anyone can
be Carrie Lake's lawyer that that we
figured out and that is abundantly clear
so uh there's not going to be a new
election Katie Hobbs is going to be the
governor of Arizona Katie Hobbs won
Kerry Lake loss but before we completely
get off of this topic I have to show you
someone who truly does seem to be living
in an alternate universe
the science tells us that one of the
best ways to get consistent deep sleep
is lowering your core body temperature
when your body stays cooler at night
you're more comfortable and your sleep
is better our sponsor sleep me is the
home of chili sleep the customizable
climate controlled sleep solutions that
can improve your sleep by keeping you
cooler at night there are three
different chili sleep systems there's
the uler the cube and the new Doc Pro
with double the cooling power all three
systems are water-based temperature
controlled mattress toppers that fit
over your existing mattress to provide
you with your ideal sleep temperature
you can go as cool as 55 degrees you can
go really hot if you want I keep mine at
60. beautiful temperature for me
don't wake up hot and sweaty chilly
sleep keeps me asleep all night it feels
great I didn't know it was possible to
love sleeping even more than I already
did go to sleep.me slash Pacman to learn
more and get 25 off your new chili Sleep
System click the link below to start
staying cool at night